you don't even show up with discuss a
hot day I can't say enough about to
change the direction off the dribble
scam shows you that first one Isakson
always says where did he go when he went
to the rim and he finished at the rim
then the next trip down little spin
contact use the left flex yep we know
you strong is on James pull up for a
three here it comes in there it goes
splash from downtown the ball goes down
to the bourbons pass picked off keys a
great play rest condition
by the young fella throw on the ball
look the beautiful ultra when the Lakers
are at their best in the lack of suit
[Music]
watch Kevin Durant Hayes if he waited
for everybody to try to find their own
men are down by just as we look to for
one situation potentially Durant goes
around the world and punches it home
over a vodka this former OKC teammate we
don't need a three but you need a store
right
I've been Durant dropped one on your
kisses head snap to tie the game
[Applause]
for being down ten with three minutes
left his 12th career triple-double and
Kevin Durant's dropping the triple
that shot and I think it's surprising
you got that open now Kyrie picked up by
watch okay
I want to see the game yeah right before
that say any cat too far underneath even
rhyme for takeoff but that that move
right there I thought the file was there
you see it got a body up 33 for Irving
34 for wall he'll take a long three his
fourth three-pointer of the game on is
preparing for a screen he's preparing
for the wizardry of Kyrie Irving and
Kyrie senses at and sees that and just
Rises it fires he waived everyone away
so he could get the hit tration good
shot my tights to get back in the play
that time and get the deflection rivers
try the lava to compel we got a good one
going get some popcorn baby behind the
back Richardson turned it over
Kairi
see the pass again
the field for for for sweet
[Music]
27 for Russell letter by Leonard gets up
the floor quick he knows exactly what
he's doing take a look at his eyes
throws it down that's been an area where
the Nets have been excellent escape
transition defense getting back
[Applause]
Leonard
[Applause]
aid here Hawaiian let it play the city
game it coming
no he hasn't gotten on track 68020 yeah
in this game Crowder has it's a call by
30 the left this is spectacular
contact all the way and somehow able to
stretch and get that ball in clean
without using the glass wow that's
impressive there's a little more emotion
and I saw he was fed up at the beginning
of the game maybe taking a couple of
plays he doesn't usually like that
trying to loosen up but this starts with
the defense and and with emotional games
like this if you're in the playoffs you
you have a bigger goal it's it's a team
win
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a half a hundy forehead bet play
in this game tonight here's another
opportunity gets hit on the elbow as he
drains another step-back three that's
now 6 for 11 from the three-point line
who was sitting right here for that
seventh game of the Western Conference
final in astonishment
[Music]
[Applause]
you got a basketball get don't dawn away
the law of game that's so effective
between me and James Harden great dish
underneath cappella sit-in plus a foul
he feels like his guy is hung up the
rotation a little bit late and this is
where a cappella how about that pass
right between the defender and levert
comes in averaging 21 and five of the
first front like a pinball resolve got
eye contact st. no it's coming he's got
to make the correct pass Drew's got
Alfred and he's got any other trail
[Applause]
get it but please like this
[Applause]
Wow
let them take your picture
try to get it back to towns does towns
lost it decision Gibson gets rejected
davus that's some block right there and
curry curry screens for thompson again
he fires again
good day y'all just deliver only ya
trying to give this good these get yes
get him
52 points timeout pulls back with 453
left in the third
[Applause]
expect this from clay but he was closely
guarded by Jackson so we went by him
moving a contact there but the officials
are letting and the players decide who
wins what a play by klay Thompson the
presence of mind to stay with it and
shoot it without coming down Stephanie
threw it away
it was deflected and now Lillard pin
liver up for three
goodness
then the game
[Music]
deflection steel
[Applause]
[Music]
Miller got it back and hit the three
five point one left in overtime of the
Warriors down one
Gordon can't bow
so forget a jump shot we get a three
give it to Koran if he can go inside
they can't bali kebun
[Applause]
and excuse me
all times damian lillard knows what a
basket is so he goes in and throws it
over Millsap gets over there a little
too low a little bit late but there to
save time we've seen time and time again
coach yells at the players in regards to
being in Hillside
[Applause]
hello
taking it home well those tough passes
yeah
I'm sure you've run the floor and had
some really weird passes communal pass
they're simply a slant for Simmons he is
playing with a lot more emotion after
showing some unusual emotion and picking
up a tactic yeah and you can see how
Afonso McKenna is time green lurking to
help behind the pack Green steps under
him trying to land that's a heck of a
pass by Simmons a jump hook right here
and I see what dream on green is talking
about the fans know about Landry shamit
the rookie out of Wichita State as you
look at Ben Simmons and it's two nothing
with the dump in the face of P Alicia
shot clock at two Aldridge has to fire
I'll be sensitive but the shot clock
expiring
coming out warriors offensive trip for
the Spurs but no it's Sunday
clearly the bank is open that turn
against Justin and go right back listen
they know where their bread is buttered
yes sir they went into this guy to
Aldrich down the stretch here he is
right here just blows right by Robin why
not play through you're off slow he
gives a little shot fake and Robin gives
in the baseline four to shoot
Wiggins has to go Wiggins pull-up jumper
no town to rebound budget fly
karl-anthony towns drills it at the
buzzer
I can't a strumpet finished for the
Grizzlies look
[Music]
towns what great awareness to get him
out of his hands and he got it away in
time they will count the bucket the
Timberwolves are walk-off winners
[Applause]
karl-anthony towns Jim he was in foul
trouble all night but he came up big
excellent job by pulling it out there in
hedge on Andrew Wiggins get back to his
own town trying to take advantage with
the Yogi's out of the game just infused
basic quad weakness right there the part
of karl-anthony towns who might have got
away with a little bit little hook here
too with the off arm he kind of got into
the chest earring right there get out of
my way he'll want to pass what a
sequence slams it in
[Music]
Bradley's complaining about being pushed
most familias Silva hard to see on that
angle auto for three he'll for three
proudly being with his sixth
three-pointer ties the game at 1:24 can
you believe that 40 points offensive
rebound and a fortuitous tip right to
him it's gets the ball back Collins has
it but throws it to a Heat player and
that's Jones gets it ahead to wade leads
it wonderful pass for the Derrick Jones
Jam but this is just a beautiful pass
here now you got a young guy coming down
who was a former slam dunk champion this
goes up and gets it second foul on every
tie him a 61 weight gets it off
great chapter two in the first half
wait jumper under duress is scoring half
of justice Winslow's career 18 points on
the first half for Winslow and flowing
some time to think of it give me where
you think Wade ranks all-time and two
guards in the NBA I guess he just went
up the ladder up the ladder so so that
was right on time right there